la Baya est une tenue inventée par les
Bédouins contre la chaleur et puis ça
s'est répandu ça n'a rien à voir avec la
religion je pense à tous ces professeurs
qui demain matin vont se retrouver dans
une situation où finalement puisque ce
n'est pas un vêtement religieux puisque
c'est simplement un vêtement comme si
comme ça voilà alors ça sert plus à rien
la Baya n'est pas un problème le
problème de l'école c'est le nombre de
profs qui manquent l'insuffisance de
l'accueil l'impossibilité de discuter de
discuter ce personnage là et voyez je
suis très dur ce soir avec lui ce
prétend avoir été un grand républicain
un grand républicain de dire cela qui
est un mensonge c'est un mensonge ce
matin c'est ouvert le salon du Bourget
c'est le plus grand dans le monde pour
le secteur aéronautique il n'avait plus
eu lieu depuis 4 ans alors que
l'aéronautique redémarre le chef de
l'État a voulu montrer qu'il se tenait
aux côtés du secteur c'est diffusé les
innovations qu'on a et on a des avions
aujourd'hui qui par rapport aux
générations d'avant et bien consomme 20
à 30% de moins ensuite ces deux diffuser
ces fameux carburants durables et safs
et de permettre de les incorporer parce
que là aussi ils réduisent très
fortement vos émissions elle vient à
peine d'être élue mère de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins qu'elle est déjà
menacée Dorothé Paco a déposer trois
plaintes en 10 jours une quatrième est
envisagée en raison de messages haineux
notamment de la part de mouvance
d'extrême droite Éric Zemmour va porter
plainte contre l'État et la CGT après
l'attaque d'une séance de dédicace à
Brest fonce ça me fait pas peur je
déplore juste l'énergie que ça que ça
que ça suppose et je le déplore dans le
sens où c'est une toute petite minorité
personne s'est défendu je vous assure je
vous assure on n'a pas eu le temps les
gens étaient blessés j'ai vu des pauvres
femmes avec des hématomes énormes voyez
non il y a pas eu de tension il y a eu
une agression absolument scandaleuse
cela se passe ainsi depuis trois mois
dans toutes les villes de France où je
vais on a entre 200 et 300 personnes qui
me harcèlent et qui me pourrissent comme
ça la vie le Syndicat de la magistrature
a publié une contre circulaire relative
au traitement judiciaire des infractions
commises par des manifestants les
syndicats dénoncent entre autres un
maintien de l'ordre intrinsèquement
violent la réalité démontre au contraire
un dévoiement du maintien de l'ordre
contre les manifestants eux-mêmes
utilisations des NAS garde à vue
préventive violence constatée sur des
manifestants défilant pacifiquement
intervention sur des cortèges sans
difficulté apparentes ça serait pas vous
le problème
c'est bien ça comme comme donc ça veut
dire que partout où les gens sont
agressés c'est eux le problème ça peut
nous mener loin à cette histoire dans le
Journal du Dimanche le président des
républicains dénonce un document
édifiant c'est un appel à contourner les
instructions du garde des sceaux
l'objectif est assumé encourager les
juges à ne pas appliquer les consignes
de leur ministre de tutelle qui sème le
vent récolte la tempête mais moi
tout ça il faut supprimer la démocratie
il faut dire que il y a des idées
interdites une aubaine pour les Black
Blocs qui détiennent avec ce document un
permis de casser les cagoule noir
peuvent courir en paix c'est complices à
coldermine assureurs
ce matin lors des assises consacrés au
désendettement de la France chacun doit
être davantage responsabiliser du
salarié au chef d'entreprise en passant
par le médecin l'absentéisme ne peut pas
être une fatalité en France quelle est
la pire date que nous avons aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est la
dette budgétaire ou est-ce que la date
écologique quand dans ma génération un
tiers des oiseaux ont disparu les deux
tiers des vertébrés ont disparu qu'on
sait pas si demain l'eau sera buvable
les respirable la planète habitable et
tout ce qu'ils ont à dire c'est la dette
la dette la dette c'est Alicante en
Espagne ou un requin bleu de 2 mètres
environ à semer la terreur chez les
baigneurs qui barbotaient au bord de
l'eau l'animal qui précisons le est
inoffensif pour l'homme